these howling monkeys are native to the
Costa Rican rainforest these students
are visiting with their professor the
earth University students are here to
learn about the rainforest firsthand
instead of from a textbook porque si la
vamos psychiatrist presenter the palm
tree is known for its large leaves as we
can see they're the world's largest
leaves a botanical record the earth
University campus is a two-hour drive
northeast of the capital San Jose here
the students learn about agricultural
and environmental technology and they
get plenty of hands-on experience too
Bert Coleman heads the Center for
research and development of renewable
energy in less than 10 years Costa Rica
plans to meet all its electricity needs
with renewables
Bendita como muchisimas Costa Rica has
many excellent options when it comes to
renewable energy we have solar energy
geothermal energy biomass water power
and wind power we have all of that here
in Costa Rica in Costa Rica the lectures
are in English
around two-thirds of the students come
from abroad I'm from Nicaragua my name
is Francisco Leyva and we I I think we
with this course I can use all the
knowledge to you say in my region
because we we have a lot of wind energy
and also solar energy the students go
wherever there's environmental
technology even on top of a roof this
solar energy unit heats water and what I
have here is a little handheld infrared
thermometer so if you hold that to the
collector and press the button then you
can read what the temperature of the
collector is at the moment it's
registering thirty five degrees Celsius
the entire campus maintains high
environmental standards every newcomer
from students to professors spends at
least one day here sorting waste cans
and plastic bottles are all recycled
that's good for the environment because
incinerating them would generate harmful
co2 organic waste is also important when
it's returned to the soil as compost it
finds co2 these simple techniques help
the university operate in a sustainable
and climate neutral way if you want to
become carbon neutral something very
important to look at when you're doing
your carbon balances is what kind of
waste are you producing and what are you
doing with it
about 1/4 of Costa Rica's population
lives in San Jose and only about 25% of
the plastic bottles used here are
recycled a lot of waste ends up in the
river
Costa Rica has ambitious environmental
and climate protection goals but there's
still a long way to go
some students are on their way to lomas
de la alegría south of earth University
for some more hands-on experience
they're going to build a simple biogas
plant most of the plant will be built
out of used parts old buckets will be
used to make large pipes this works well
in small communities it's a way to build
biogas plants cheaply and this is what
the plant looks like when it's finished
the wastewater generated by this
household will be transported through
the containers and bacteria removed that
will generate methane we're saving about
10,000 colonias of gas each month that
works out to a savings of about 15 euros
the wastewater has been converted into
energy
back at the campus
the university also runs a banana
plantation it's also being operated
sustainably the campus plantation will
serve as a model for Costa Rica's large
commercial operations insects and other
small creatures are also important
they help loosen the soil the campus
plantation also uses as little chemical
fertilizer and pesticides as possible
most commercial farms will put
pesticides within these to kill any
insects that are within the bunches we
however use a combination of chili and
hot pepper the workers also benefit they
earn more than the local minimum wage
which is equivalent to about 400 euros
per month the bananas are sold abroad
the profits go to fund scholarships for
20 students it costs about 17 thousand
euros a year to attend Earth University
but only a few students pay the full
cost on their own over the years we have
been able to convince friends donors
companies governments including the
German government to support an
institution like this to support these
kids to come and at this kind of
education so that we can break that
circle of poverty we can improve the
their conditions and they can improve
their family their community their
countries
in return they're now recording a video
message a message of thanks from 400
students and professors from 30
different countries